สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะวันนี้
เราเจอกันวันพุธ
ค่ะวัน
พุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
9 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤศจิกายน
โอเคปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะโคตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 14
น 13 น
13 นาที
อือืนี่ละค่ะวันพุธนะคะ 1413 น
แล้วร้อนมยครูเรียมร้อนมากค่ะครู
ฟ้ากี่องศาคะของครูเรียมตอนนี้บ้านูเรียม
กี่องศาเซลเซียเดี๋ยวเรียมดูนะได้
32 ค่ะครูฟ้าอากาอาศ
ร้อนร้อนมากที่บ้านครูฟ้าล่ะคะกี่องศาที่
บ้าครูฟ้า 31 องศเซซ
ค่ะใกล้ๆกันร้อนเหมือนกันครูฟ้าได้ออกไป
นอกบ้านมยคะออกไปนอกบ้านหรอครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็
คิดเอว่าอยากออกไปนอกบ้านนะคะเพราะว่า
อยู่ในบ้านก็
ร้อนก็เลยคิดออกไปนอกบ้านดีมย
น้าว่าอยากไปซื้อตุ๊กตาค่ะช่วงนี้
อ๋อไปซื้อที่ไหนคะู
ฟ้าไปซื้อที่
เอิ่มเรียกอะไรอ่ะห้างนะคะไปซื้อที่ห้าง
เอ่อซื้อตุ๊กตาครเรียมให้ครูฟ้าแชร์สกรีน
ได้ไหมมอ๋อได้ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะนี่นะคะห้าง
รูฟ้าชอบตุ๊กตาอะไรคะตุ๊กตาหรอูฟ้า
เสิร์ชแป๊บนึง
นะนะฮะครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะไปที่
นี่พัทยานะคะเพราะว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้าอยู่
พัทยานี่คือห้างนะคะนักเรียนไปห้างใช่ไหม
Terminal  2  One พัทยาว่าจะไปซื้อ
ตุ๊กตาค
อืออเรียมคไปมอเรียมเพิ่งจะรู้วันนี้ว่า
ที่พัทยามี Terminal
21 เหรอใช่เอ่อนี่ค่ะ Terminal  21 พัยา
ค่ะออเป็นห้างนะคะเป็นห้างอืมีขายเสื้อ
ผ้าขายเมอขายอาหารขายรองเท้าขายทุกอย่าง
ที่เทอมอลอฟ้าก็เลยจะไปขาุเรียมจะไปซื้อ
ซื้อ
ของใช่วะจะไปซื้อตุ๊กตานี่ตุ๊กตาเห็น
ไมอันนี้เป็นตุ๊กตาไม้นะคะตุ๊กตาไม้นี่
เลยเนี่ย
ออรียมน่ารักมั้ยครูฟ้าจะไปซื้อตุ๊กตาไม้
ใช่ค่ะน่ารักใช่ค่ะูฟ้าเดินไปหรอคะฟ้า
เดินไปหรอฟ้าจะไป
ขับรถไปค่ะ
อ๋อขับรถไปใช่ขับรถไปไปซื้อตุ๊กตานะคะ
ตุ๊กตาไม้นี่เลยแล้วก็ตุ๊กตาตัวนี้ที่ครู
เรียมเห็นเลยนะคะอยากได้ตัวนี้เลยตัวนี้
เลยตัวนี้เลยค่ะจริงๆตุ๊กตาตัวนี้นะคะก็
คือตุ๊กตาพิน็อกคิโอ
ออเดี๋ยวเราก็อาจจะได้เล่าเล่ากันในคลิป
อื่นอ้าเหรออ้าใช่มั้ยหรือว่าคลิปนี้เรา
เราเอาอะไรก่อนเออลืมเอาครูพาก่อนก็ได้นะ
คะก็คือได้ๆๆอ๋อพิน็อกคิโอนั่นแหละพิโอ
อ๋อตุ๊กตาพิโอนะคะนเรียแบบเอ๊ะครูพูดอะไร
กันไม่มีอะไรนะคะนักเรียนมีอะไกลังงงๆนิด
หน่อยใช่ๆนะคะซึ่งนี่แหละตุ๊กตาไม้ที่ครู
ฟ้าอยากได้จริงๆเนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบตุ๊กตาไม้
เอ่อนัทแครกเกอร์จะเป็นตุ๊กตาไม้อีกแบบ
นึงนะคะแล้วครูฟ้าก็ซื้อมาแล้วตอนนี้ครู
ฟ้าก็เลยอยากได้ตุ๊กตาพินอคคิโอเป็น
ตุ๊กตาไม้พินอคคิโอที่ให้นักเรียนดูเมื่อ
กี้นี่แหละอือ๋อครูฟ้าบอกว่าเคยซื้อ
ตุ๊กตาไม้นัดแครกเกอร์มาแล้วอืใช่แล้วก็
เราก็ได้เล่าแล้วก็คุยกันเรื่องนัด
แครกเกอร์ไปแล้วใช่ค่ะวันนี้ครูฟ้าอยาก
ได้ตุ๊กตาไม้
พินอคคิโอใช่ครูฟ้ามาเล่าเรื่องพิคเคิล
มั้ยคะเรียมรู้ได้ยัง
ไงเก่งมากเก่งมากค่ะเก่งมากนะคะซึ่งใช่
ค่ะวันนี้ครูฟ้าก็เลยมีเรื่องของ
พิน็อกคิโอมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังนั่นเอง
อืพินอคคิโอเนี่ยเป็นตุ๊กตานะคะตุ๊กตามาย
ที่ครูฟ้าโชว์ให้ดูนะ
คะแต่เรื่องของพินอคคิโอเนี่ยพินอคคิโอ
เนี่ยก็จะมีหลายเวอร์ชั่นเนาะมีเวอร์ชั่น
ที่เป็นการ์ตูนว Disney นะคะนักเรียนก็ไป
หาดูได้เป็นการ์ตูนแล้วก็เวอร์ชั่นที่
เป็นนิทานก็คือนิทานที่ครูฟ้าเอามาเล่า
วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นเวอร์ชั่นนิทานนะคะนิทาน
เนาะอืเวอร์ชั่นดินนี่กับเวอร์ชั่นนิทาน
ไม่เหมือนกันหรอคะรูบาคิดว่าไม่เหมือนกัน
ค่ะอาจจะคล้ายๆกันแต่มีเปลี่ยนนิดหน่อยก็
เลยไม่เหมือนกันอออโอเคในเวอร์ชั่นนิทาน
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะครูฟาในเวอร์ชั่นนิทาน
เนี่ยก็จะมีเรื่องเนี่ยก็เกิดขึ้นที่มี
ผู้ชายคนนึงอืผู้ชายคนนึงนะคะผู้ชายคนนี้
เนี่ยอายุมากแล้วค่ะครูเรียมอายุมาก
ประมาณ 80 ปีมั้ยคะคิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ
70 เออประมาณ 70 นะคะอายุ 70 อืม 70 นะ
คะนักเรียนผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยชื่อว่าเจทเพต
เจทเพตนะคะเจเพตอืน่าจะเป็นคนประเทศอะไร
นะอิตาลีสเปนหรืออะไรรึเปล่าเจ็เพตไม่รู้
จริงๆนะไม่รู้ถ้าเถนักเรียนรู้ก็คอมเมนต์
มาใช่ค่ะเจเพตเนี่ยเขาคเป็นช่างไม้
ค่ะเปิดช่างไม้เนาะช่าง
ไม้แป๊บนึงนะ
คะนี่นะคะนี่คือช่างไม้เห็นมั้ยคะนัก
เรียนก็จะทำไม้มีไม้มีไม้มีไม้นี่ช่างไม้
ทำเฟอร์นิเจอร์ได้นะนะคะแต่ว่าจะเป็น
เฟอร์นิเจอร์ที่เป็นไม้อันเนี้ยคือไม้
อืไม้เห็นมยแล้วก็จะทำเกี่ยวกับไม้ม้ม้นะ
คะนี่คือช่างไม้ผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็คือช่างไม้
อืมนะคะเหมือน
อ่าเหมือน
กับกดผิดนะแป๊บนึงเจเพโตเนี่ยเจเพโตเนี่ย
เป็นผู้ชายที่เป็นช่างไม้
อืแล้วก็อายุประมาณ 70 แล้วนะคะ 70 ซึ่ง
เจเพตเนี่ย
ไม่มี
ภรรยาไม่มี
ลูกไม่มีครอบครัวเลยค่ะครูเรียงอ้าวเค้า
อยู่คนเดียวเหรอคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะอยู่คน
เดียวมีบ้านแล้วก็อยู่บ้านคนเดียวเออบ้าน
ก็เป็นบ้านเก่าๆไม่ได้รวยมากอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยอืไเวลาที่เราอยู่คน
เดียวเราก็เหงาใช่มั้ยคะนักเรียน
เหงาคิดว่าคิดว่าจะเหงานะคะเหมือนครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าอยู่คนเดียวหรือเปล่าตอนนี้ครูฟ้า
อยู่คนเดียวค่ะในห้อง
อืเพราะเห็นครูฟ้าชอบซื้อ
ตุ๊กตาใช่ตุ๊กตามาเก็บไว้ที่ห้องมาเก็บ
ไว้ที่ห้องค่ะก็เลยเพราะครูฟ้าเหงาไงครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยแต่ครูฟ้ายังมีคุณพ่อคุณแม่นะคะ
แต่ว่าบางทีครูฟ้าก็จะเหงาถ้าครูฟ้าอยู่
คนเดียวใช่ไหมเจเพตเนี่ยเขาก็อยู่คนเดียว
และเขาไม่มีภรรยาไม่มีลูกไม่มีพ่อแม่ไม่
มีครอบครัวไม่มี
เพื่อนเค้าก็จะเหงามากๆเค้าคุยกับใครอ่ะ
ไม่มีเลยเห็นมเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเหงานะคะ
เจ๊เพชต้มยทำยังไงดีคะครูฟ้าก็วันนึง
เนี่ยเจโต้เค้าก็นั่งแล้วก็คิดถ้าเค้ามี
ลูกก็คงจะดีนะอืมก็คงจะดีนะคะเค้าก็เลย
เค้าเป็นช่างไม้ใช่มยก็เลยเอาไม้เนี่ยมา
ทำทำๆๆๆทำตุ๊กตาขึ้นมา 1
ตัวออ๋อตุ๊กตาเด็กหรอคะตุ๊กตาเด็กค่ะครู
เหลี่ยมแป๊บนึงนะ
ว้า
ให้ดูรูปนะ
คะมีรูปภาพเดี๋ยวให้ดูเป็นตุ๊กตาเด็กเป็น
เด็กผู้ชายหรือเด็กผู้หญิงคะครูฟ้าเด็ก
ผู้ชายค่ะนี่ไงเจ็เพโตคนนี้นะคะแล้วก็ทำ
ตุ๊กตาเด็กอืมเด็กผู้ชายเห็นไมมีคิ้วมีตา
มีจมูกมี
ปากแล้วก็มีผมด้วยเป็นเด็กผู้ชายเลยนะคะ
อืว้าวนี่คือตุ๊กตาที่เขาทำนะคะก็เจพโต้
เนี่ยก็ทำตุ๊กตาขึ้นมาแล้วก็ให้ชื่อว่า
พินอคคิโออือืซึ่งหลังจากที่เปโตทำตุ๊กตา
พินอคคิโอเสร็จก็รู้สึกเหนื่อยแล้วก็ไป
นอนระหว่างที่เจเพโตไปนอนนะคะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นคาูฟ้ามีนางฟ้าค่ะ
มานางฟ้าเรียมว่าได้มั้ยฟ้าได้ค่ะแต่ครู
ว่ามีรูปนะเปิดรูปก็ได้ได้ๆๆๆนี่
ไงนี่คือนางฟ้าค่ะนักเรียน
ออเห็นมยนี่นะคะนางฟ้ามีปีกมีคาฑา
เป็นนางฟ้าอือืนางฟ้าเนี่ยก็เข้ามาในบ้าน
ของเจสเพโต
อ่าแล้วก็นางฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่าเจท petto
เนี่ยเป็นคนดีนะคะเป็นคนดีมากๆนางฟ้าก็
เลยจะให้พินอคคิโอเนี่ยมี
ชีวิตว้าแต่ Pinocchio เป็นหุ่นไม้นะคุณู
ฟ้าใช่ปกติพินอคคิโอเป็นหุ่นเป็นตุ๊กตา
ใช่มยแต่พินอคคิโอเนี่ยพูดไม่ได้เดินไม่
ได้เป็นตุ๊กตาแต่นางฟ้าเนี่ยก็ทำให้
พินอคคิโอมีชีวิตพูดได้เดินได้คิดได้นะคะ
นี่คือมีชีวิตมีหัวใจว้าวเก็จะมีชีวิต
ขึ้นมาเห็นมยแล้วนางฟ้าไม่ถามไม่ถามแบบ
เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรนะที่คนที่เป็นช่างไม้
ก่อนหรอเจเพโตหรอก็เจเพโตเเหงาเเจเพโต
อยากได้ลูกชายไงนะคะน้องฟ้าก็เลยคิดว่า
อยากได้แน่นอนก็หลังจากนั้นเนี่ย
พิน็อกคิโอก็เป็นเด็กผู้ชายเออมีชีวิตนะ
คะเดินได้นางฟ้าก็บอกว่าให้พินอคคิโอเป็น
เด็กดีนะอืมเป็นเด็กดีฟังคุณพ่อฟังเจบ
เพโตพูดอืก็จะเป็นเด็กดีนะอะไรอย่างงั้น
นะคะอซึ่งถ้าพิน็อกคิโอเป็นเด็กดี
พินอคคิโอจะกลายเป็นคน 1
100% ว้าวโอดีมากอืแต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นเด็ก
ไม่ดีเหรอคะก็จะเป็นตุ๊กตาต่อไปนะคะนั่น
แหละซึ่งเจเพโตเนี่ยก็ตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วก็
เห็นพิน็อกคิโอมี
ชีวิตเจเพโตก็ดีใจมากค่ะดีใจดีใจดีใจดีใจ
แล้วก็พูดกับพินอคคิโอว่าพินอคคิโอต่อไป
เนี้ยเธอเป็นลูกของฉันเป็นลูกชายแล้วต้อง
เป็นเด็กดีนะต้องไปเรียนหนังสือทำได้ย
ให้พินอคคิโอไปเรียนหนังสือนะคะอืมมีคุณ
ครูแล้วพินอคคิโอก็ไปเรียนหนังสือถูกมั้ย
คะนิโอก็ไปเรียนหนังสือค่ะแล้วก็บอกว่า
พินอคคิโอเนี่ย
สัญญาว่าจะไปเรียนหนังสือทุกวันจะตั้งใจ
เรียนมากๆ
อ่าแล้วพี่นอคคิโอก็เลยไปโรงเรียนค่ะวัน
นึงเนี่ยที่กำลังไปโรงเรียนเนี่ย
พิน็อคคิโอก็ไปเจอกับหมาป่า 1 ตัว
อืหมาป่าเดี๋ยวพเปิดหม้าป่าให้
ดูนี่นะคะคือหมมาป่า
เบเบหมาป่าอันนี้แมวหรือเปล่าอันนั้นแมว
หมาป่าเป็นคนไม่ดีแน่นอนนะคะดูหน้าก็รู้
ใช่นิทานทุกเรื่องหมา
ป่าหมาป่าตัวสีสมไม่ดีแมวตัวสีเหลืองใช่
แล้วค่ะก็พินอคคิโอเนี่ยก็เจอกับหมาป่านะ
คะหมาป่าเนี่ยก็กำลังเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะ
เหมือนเรียก
คนทุกคนทุกคนมีใครอยากดูโชว์มยมีโชว์นะ
อ่ามีโชว์อยากดูโชว์มยโชว์ตุ๊กตาไม้อืหื
เป็นโชว์ของตุ๊กตาไม้เวลาตุ๊กตาก็จะมี
อย่างนี้ใช่มั้ยตุ๊กตาแล้วก็มีโชว์นะคะ
หมาป่าก็เรียกให้ทุกคนมาดูโชว์พี่นคิโอ้
เนี่ยสนใจก็เลยเดินเข้า
ไปแล้วก็อยากไปดูโชว์ด้วยหมาป่าก็ถาม
พินอคคิโอมีเงินมั้ยอืมพินอคคิโอตอบว่า
ยังไงคะเอ้อจะไปดูโชว์ต้องมีเงิน
พินอคคิโอเนี่ยบอกว่าไม่มีเงินเลยอ้าไม่
มีเงินแล้วทำยังไงหมาป่าเนี่ยคิดขอพ่อ
มั้ยขอพ่อพี่น้องิโอเคิดว่าจะไม่ดูค่ะจะ
กลับบ้านจะกลับไปโรงเรียนจะไปโรงเรียนแต่
มาหมาป่าเนี่ยก็มีไอเดียนะคะหมาป่าเห็น
พินอคคิโอเนี่ยเป็นตุ๊กตาไม้อยากจับ
พินอคคิโอไปโชว์แล้วจะได้เงินเยอะ
อ่าหมาป่าก็เลยบอกพิน็อกคิโอว่า
พิน็อกคิโอ
ถ้าอยากดูโชว์เนี่ยก็เอาหนังสือมาหนังสือ
เรียนน่ะเอามาแล้วก็ไปดูโชว์ได้ฟรีเลย
อ้าวแล้วพิคคี้เอาหนังสือเรียนให้หมาป่า
มยคะคให้ค่ะก็ให้หมาป่าแล้วก็พี่นิโอก็
เลยไม่ไปเรียน
อืมเพื่อที่จะไปดูโชว์นะคะซึ่งพอ
พิน็อกคิโอได้ไปดูโชว์กับหมาป่าแล้วเนี่ย
หมาป่าก็จับพินอคคิโอขัง
ไว้ในกรงครุเรียมวาดกรงได้มยมีกรงขอบคุณ
ค่ะคังไว้ในกรงไม่ได้กรง
อืพี่น้องคีโอก็ร้องไหร้องไห้อยู่ในกรงนะ
คะนี่นี่คือ
กรงอืมดนจับ
ไว้แต่ระหว่างที่พินอคคิโอร้องไห้เนี่ย
นางฟ้าก็
มาแล้วก็มาถามว่าทำไมพินอคคิโอถึงมาอยู่
ที่นี่ทำไมไม่ไปเรียน
หนังสืออืพี่นคิโอ้เนี่ยกลัวนางฟ้าว่านะ
คะก็เลยโกหกไปว่าโดนหมาป่าจับ
มาหมาป่าเนี่ยไปหาพินอคคิโอแล้วก็จับ
พินอคคิโอมา
อ๋อพินอคคิโอ
โกหกใช่แต่พอพินอคคิโอโกหกแล้วนะคะจมูก
ของพินอคคิโอเนี่ยก็ยาวขึ้นยาวขึ้นยาว
ขึ้น
อ้านางฟ้าก็เลยบอกว่านี่ไงเพราะว่า
พินอคคิโอเนี่ยโกหกทำให้จมูกยาวขึ้นแล้ว
จมูกจะกลับเข้ามาได้มั้ยคะนางฟ้าก็เลยบอก
ว่าให้พี่นิโอสัญญาได้มยถ้าเป็นเด็กดีไม่
พูดโกหกจมูกก็จะเป็นปกติแล้วพินอคคิโอก็
จะได้กลับ
บ้านพินอคคิโอก็บอกว่าสัญญาสัญญาว่าจะไม่
พูดโกหกจะเป็นเด็กดีจะไปเรียนหนังสืออื
หลังจากนั้นนางฟ้าก็เลยช่วยให้พินอคคิโอ
เนี่ยได้กลับบ้านนะคะกลับไปหาคุณพ่ออืมเจ
เพตนั่นแหละเจเพตนะคะก็จริงๆมันมีสตอรี่
ที่ยาวกว่านี้นะคะในการ์ตูนแต่สุดท้าย
แล้วเนี่ยพินอคคิโอก็ได้กลับไปหาเจเพตนะ
คะแล้วก็พินอคคิโอเนี่ยก็พูดดีๆไม่พูด
โกหกแล้วก็เป็นเด็กดีตั้งใจเรียนหนังสือ
อือ๋อจากนั้นเนี่ยนางฟ้าก็เลยทำให้
พินอคคิโอเป็นเป็นคนแบบ 100% อ๋ออันนี้
เป็นเวอร์ชั่นนิทานเวอร์ชั่นนิทานค่ะใช่
เพราะว่าถ้าเวอร์ชั่นของดิสนีย์ก็จะมี
สตอรี่มากกว่านี้นะคะอืใช่แล้วครูฟ้าคิด
ยังไงคะถ้าเวลาที่ครูฟ้าหรือว่าเรียมพูด
โกหกแล้วจมูกก็จะยาวออกมาถ้าครูฟ้าเป็น
เด็กๆครูฟ้าอาจจะกลัวนะคะแล้วครูฟ้าก็จะ
ไม่พูดโกหกเพราะว่ากลัวจมูก
ยาวใช่โกหกไม่ได้โโกหกคนอื่นก็รู้ว่าโกหก
อยู่ใช่ๆเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้าเราไม่พูด
โกหกมันก็อาจจะคือถ้าเราพูดโกหกมันก็ไม่
ดีอยู่แล้วมะอืมไม่ดีอยู่แล้วมั้ยคะมัน
แล้วแต่นะบางคนก็พูดโกหกเพื่อสิ่งดีๆบาง
คนก็พูดโกหกแล้วไม่ดีก็ต้องดูด้วยนะคะแต่
ว่าจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยเราไม่ควรพูดโกหกอืม
เพราะว่าจมูกเราจะยาวไม่ใช่ออเหรอเราไม่
ใช่
พินอคคิโอเราไม่ใช่พินอคคิโอใช่ไหมมใช่
ค่ะอืนั่นแหละแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาก็หมดแล้ว
ค่ะครูฟ้าันนี้เวลาก็หมดแล้วนะคะนี่แหละ
ค่ะครูฟ้าก็เลยมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังเป็น
เรื่องสั้นๆครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะไปซื้อตุ๊กตา
พินอคคิโอแล้วนะคะนักเรียนวันนี้ครูฟ้า
กับครูเลียมก็คงต้องไปก่อนนะคะไปก่อนหรอ
ค่ะครูฟ้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะสวัดีค่ะบ๊าย
[เพลง]
บายเรียมสวยตืดตื่นไม่ใช่
นะ